Oh, my heart is racing.
Mine, too.
It's hard to hold the camera still.
My hands are shaking.
Yeah.
I also kind of feel sad for them.
You know, this was their home.
They're so adorable and they had their big adventure,...
...and it was really hard for them to part with it.
And yeah, I can understand that.
I can feel the transfer of energy into ours...
...in that, becoming our place.
But it's kind of cool because it has so much history.
So many different people have had their adventures in this car, too.
So it's like…
Yeah, I mean, it's 30 years old.
It's 30 years old, and I feel that there's something so beautiful about it,...
...that it's been passed down and you don't even know what adventures it's seen.
Yeah, there's so many cute little details I like,...
...like this, I don't know what that is covering.
I don't know.
I feel that's the beauty of when you get something,...
...like a hand-me-down or something secondhand...
...or even like an old film camera or anything.
When you have something that other people have seen and given life to you,...
...it's pretty cool to add your own experiences.
Big changes coming your way, van.
Yeah, you're gonna get a facelift.
You're gonna get a facelift.
Not even a facelift.
We're stripping this to the bare bones and then rebuilding the entire thing.